عشان هيك احنا سالنا الناس على فكره في
السعوديه كم تنفق عاده على مشاويرك
الترفيهيه شهريا خلينا نشوف قديش قول
[موسيقى]
مصاريفي الترفيهيه الشهريه بتكون ما بين
3000 الى 5000 حقيقتين تقريبا المصروفات
الشهريه ثلاثه ونص للنفق شهريا تقريبا من
500 الى 700 شهريه
تقريبا شه
[موسيقى]
ريه
1000 ريال تقريبا والله كثير مره لو
حسبتها تقريبا ثلاث ارباع الراتب يروح
مصاريف شهريه ترفيهيه لانه
التطلعات كثيره التوجهات كثيره
كمان الواحد يحب انه يكون شغوف انه يشوف
البرامج الترفيهيه التثقيفيه وكلها تضم
دائره واحده
متوسط تقريبا من 2000 الى 3000 ريال
تقريبا المتوسط فيها لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات